[音楽]
ん
th
ha
老犬ホームぷれあです
ん
ええええええ
[音楽]
ガー
bg
からです金ちゃんサバゲやったことありません肇社長です様げったことないんですけど
もなからエアガン駑馬十駕聞いていつもこれだけ買わせていただきました
aa 時に sledgehammer んって言えあかんですけども第2部サバゲ
スってリストの中だとちょっと有名な中らしくてなんかめっちゃ強いらしいですねガス
ガンとかならばかりをガスダンパーで次のわかるんですけども年か妄想
影響レベルでめちゃくちゃ強いらしくてサバゲーだとよくこの重視を禁止になってる
らしいです痛すぎ
かっこええあった人に向けて言ってはいけません家の実際まずすごいぞ威力ちょっと見
てみましょう1回このお土産の箱言ってみます結構硬い
そこなんですけどいます
通りだっ
もう
おっか見て下さい完全に穴が空いとる後ろ農繁通信社からめっっちゃ硬いんですよ
はい
これが a 12の威力です次の皆さんこの日本イッツスナイパーにエアガンで狙わ
れるかわかりませんホストずつないパーに狙われるようなことがあれば自分で自分の身
を守らなければいけないとそんな空冷の報告ツナはないに今日私が皆さんに教え
ましょう
エアガンから自分の身を守る方法を定義でスナイパーに狙われたときどうやって自分の
身を守るが一般的に書く
られるのは自分の身の回りにあるものね自分の身を守る品がいつかんが皆さんのご家庭
にもあるでしょ
こちら食パンでございますあっ天才皆さんのご家庭にもたがあると思いますしょっぱん
ちょく版ってどこにではあるんですよ会で県警次第でスナイパーとが家に誰かに狙われ
たと言って自分の身を守ると思うので一番違うものと言えば食パンなんです足掌底が
下げた
どこの家庭にもある配合で食パンが暗殺から自分の日も一番有効な手段なんですね今回
の訓練はこの最強の映画の山道を食パン名前ですということができるのか今回検証して
いきたいと思います最強の映画を止める食パンの枚数だったらどんな映画の基本的に
食べることができます今回の実験でレイヤー眼下の準備を守る職場の必要枚性が発揮で
バブルことでしょうでは
含め返したいと寄付させていきましょう
食品衛生的な一応細心の注意を払ってやっておりますまずは一枚
ん
ぜひまず1枚目です
1枚は余裕だと思います
欲しいなんですけども1回で3発出る散弾銃なんですよね
結構それでねーよ普通にないとかあると思いますでは行きます
[音楽]
ん
ではね返ってくるだけ
上手がやっぱ食パン止めてたこのプラスチックは好まなかった
いやこれいいよくヤバイっすよまじで相手1番目クリアです次ちょっとアレで5枚でさ
せがに1枚は波すぎ
5枚結構分厚いと思うんですよ
と思いました例えば理科せていただきます職場んごめんちゃい
じゃんっ2うわぁ
いきます
あ4でも結構の結構行ってるとこれて枚目
ザーン
まってこれまたが
もうすごい場へておいてくれ
20,000円
えええええええいやいやそんなわけないでしょちょっと納得いかないんでめっちゃ緊急
言ってみて一線からちょっとあんたに入るしたら聞いて前を追った3役
さあこれじゃあ行きます
5ない see to one by one
ん
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
はぁっ
えっ
2枚ねちょっとちょっとまあちょっ待ってくださいよ
ちょっと練習をさせて祖霊舎のためチェックが違ういきます
[音楽]
さすがに入ってるぞこんなに打ち込みまあさすがに一番いい
うまいえまって
3枚ん
[音楽]
まあまままままままま単発なら
単発なる代替食パン2枚あればへ伝えることが分かりました
えーっと衝撃な結果なんですけどもこの中
振るう大津ボードがありましてないか本当にタオルにくるんだったら多分レーサーで
打ってくると思うんですよ最強の蛇で最後フルオートでレーショしまくると直感なん
ない貫通するのでしょうか
ダーツ
よくやってみよういやー
いきま
映画と本と後から今こそお見せしましょう
ついて大ファン
t ある
th
多分いれば予算結果ようです私何の間のかなぁ
1枚すごい洗います数万位
2枚
あんまないよ4枚
5倍
50,000円
[音楽]
ブーブーんっ
はいというわけで結果
なぁ5枚あればエアガンでスナイプされても多分生きられます
もっとさあもっとなんか二十五六ライカで奪っていくと思ったんですけど全然そんな
ことなかったですね食パンが強いか八かの弱いかわかんないんですけどももしエアガン
オタスナイパーに狙われているときはぜひ食パンを号
前ほど持っていれば安全だと思いますそれから食パン5枚ぐらいもって杏日外出して
ください
ざまっちゃったなぁ
みんな